was Nicole the love of your love what do
you what do you mean Peter you were
married for 10 years listen we raise
children
how do you answer that question
you know I plan on getting married again
you do oh absolutely yeah and having
kids absolutely but Nicole was a merger
part of your life and the love of your
life at the time I loved Nick very much
there's no question would you like
Nicole to remarry yes I want Nicole to
be happy that's what I want and do you
have a relationship where you you talk
it's a parenting relationship and talk
professionally about each other why
don't we why listen here's here's the
thing Peter you're stepping over a line
now you're stepping over a line you know
you are I suppose the questions that
people want to know Peter you want to
know take responsibility for what you
want to know don't say what other people
this is a conversation that I'm having
with you right now right okay so I'm
just telling you right now put your
manners back in do you think I was out
of blonde yes absolutely well I
apologize for that sincerely